something which has never occurred since
time immemorial a young woman did not
fart in her husband's lap hey 42 here
that was the world's oldest recorded
joke first told in 1900 BC in what is
now southern Iraq obviously toilet humor
is just as popular back then as always
the joke itself may not be very funny
now but in 1900 BC it would have surely
caused people to crease up with laughter
but why how come when we're told a joke
or when someone falls over or when we're
just in an awkward situation this
strange gargled grunting noise comes out
your mouth what on earth is left and why
do we do it let's find out laughter is
the most universal form of communication
unlike language which can just as easily
divide people
laughter brings people together and
unlike language everyone in the world
understands laughter and when I say
everyone I do mean everyone because
human beings are born with the ability
to laugh we don't learn to laugh it's a
basic human instinct laughter is very
powerful it can create powerful bonds
between people laughter is often a part
of the human mating ritual as well and
some people even believe laughter can
heal you oh and laughter can also be a
force for evil but we'll get to that
later one of the most surreal aspects of
laughter is that apart from fake
laughter we don't decide when to laugh
it just comes naturally
this is strong evidence that there's a
good causational reason why humans laugh
such a natural and instinctive trait
doesn't just come along by accident but
here's the kicker what if I told you
that laughing has nothing to do with a
person's sense of humor when we laugh
it's not just because you have a person
told us a joke that fits in with our
tasting comedy in fact we laugh for a
completely different reason laughter
isn't about humor it's all about being
social it's about 50
in and accepting others in a study that
was carried out over a 10-year period it
was observed that most laughter does not
follow a joke
in fact the researchers observed that
when a joke is told the person telling
the joke is much more likely to laugh
than the recipients of the joke the vast
majority of laughter actually follows
simple statements and questions such as
hey John where have you been and how did
you do on that test they don't sound
particularly funny and that's because
they're not in these situations people
laugh not because the statement is funny
but because it helps to strengthen
social bonds laughter is a means of
acceptance of what the other person is
saying a way of demonstrating that we're
both on the same page without having to
use a single word laughter is therefore
a way to show the other person that you
appreciate what they're telling you
laughter can demonstrate that you like
someone and is sometimes used to defuse
awkward situations in fact you're thirty
times more likely to laugh when other
people are around you then when you're
alone which just goes to show that
laughter is much more about bonding than
humor you're also more likely to laugh
when you're with friends as opposed to
when you're with strangers
because you're more inclined to bond
with your friends it's believed that
laughter evolved from the panting
behavior of our primate ancestors if you
tickle an ape or a gorilla they will
produce an exuberant panting noise that
noise is a primates version of laughter
but not all animals laugh so far we're
actually only aware of two animals that
laugh apes and rats but there may be
others that share this ability so get
out there and start tickling random
creatures it's believed the reason that
primates evolved the ability to laugh is
because it was an effective means of
communication and a way to strengthen
bond with their fellow beings long
before the inception of language Apes
can often be seen tickling each other
whilst playing all the while laughing
away although from our perspective it
what it really appears to be laughing
but more joy
panting if you've ever observed this
behavior you will notice that before
long the entire troupe of apes will be
merrily panting in unison this is
because laughter is incredibly
contagious in fact a great way to make
someone laugh is to start laughing
yourself although this worked remarkably
better if your own laughter is real not
faked the human brain is unbelievably
good at telling a difference between
fake laughter and real laughter in fact
laughter is so contagious that in 1962
in Tanzania
there was a laughter epidemic it all
started when free girls started laughing
in a school in kasha
before long the entire skill was
erupting in fits of laughter it was so
bad that the school had to close the
laughter soon spread to neighboring
villages and before long it had affected
hundreds of people the laughter plague
lasted for a staggering 18 months after
it started in total over a thousand
people were infected with non-stop
laughter for days on end and people
reported symptoms such as pain
flatulence attacks of praying and random
screaming laughter sure is a powerful
thing but with great power comes great
responsibility for laughter can be used
for evil it's true there's a dark side
too laughter remember when bullies would
laugh in the playground whilst causing
another person upset and misery
well that's because scientists believe
that there are two kinds of laughter the
first is spontaneous laughter that's the
kind when we laugh with our friends or
when someone tells us a joke the other
kind of laughter non spontaneous
laughter includes fake laughter nervous
laughter and evil cackling the kind of
laughter you might hear from a villain
in a James Bond film psychologists
believe that this kind of laughter is
used to show superiority and dominance
over another person when militants and
gangs attack people they have often been
witnessed to laugh whilst doing it but
why someone being violently attacked is
certainly no laughing matter
well it's believed that laughter is used
in such circumstances to form a bond
Queen the attackers and to exclude the
victim making them feel isolated and
therefore frightened laughter helps to
assert the attackers dominance and makes
them feel more powerful so to summarize
when we laugh we are accessing and
utilizing an ancient evolutionary
communication system that not only helps
to create relationships with other
humans but to also maintain and
strengthen them we can also use it to
regulate emotions show dominance over
others and even to create fear thanks
for the view subscribe for more for TTIP